in the unstable political landscape of
election 2015 there's one thing you can
count on from north to south east to
west it will be a liberal Democrat
bloodbath the party has no choice but to
circle the wagons and aim to shore up
those seats they do hold grassroots
politics it's what lib dems do best
right well here in taunton deane is a
demonstration in most constituencies
this is par for the course who's the MP
here no I don't have a clue actually
who's the MP here yes good question but
in a Lib Dem southwest stronghold that
don't knows are the exception yes Jeremy
brown and if it Jeremy brown everything
who wanted to know Jeffrey proin I think
we know who your local MP is Jerry Brown
nipple Democrat can't think of his name
Jeremy the brow brow
Jeremy Browne some ginger guy Jerry Beck
Jeremy and now it's supposed to be
Rebecca power coming up you are very
well-informed they are right on the
money the ginger guy is calling it a day
like a number of his long-standing
Liberal Democrat colleagues Jeremy brown
leaves the Tories ready to pounce and
the lib dems staring down the barrel
probably in a seat like Taunton that was
always going to be a big ask for the lib
dems losing an MP with Jeremy Browns
name recognition is a real blow however
there is a school of thought that maybe
he's been falling out of love with
Westminster politics for a little while
now an injection of fresh blood fresh
enthusiasm might not do them any harm
the stakes are high if the lib dems win
it shows they can survive even the
harshest political climate but David
Cameron's row to a Commons majority has
to lead through places like Taunton to
this is going on across the country
single seats big implications the
results in marginal constituencies that
will shape the picture of the next
parliament
you